I am wonder if you're really that  shallow  Ian certainly didn't mince words with  Kaitlyn as he seemed to shame her for  being too sexually aggressive I feel  like you're sure to make out with a  bunch of dudes on TV someone who was  notoriously aggressive in 2012 was  Courtney Robertson is so cute  Courtney wrote the best-seller I didn't  come here to make friends and says that  Fame can be as much a motive as love for  the contestants a lot of people go on to  promote their business or buying for the  next bachelor or bachelorette last night  Ian also called Caitlin out for this  comment she made two former Chris  lassies compiled the Phantom I filled  everything I came here expecting to meet  the girl that had her heart broken and  was devastated by crystals not the girl  that wanted their field Chris what  shaming is never the answer I think it's  like a blessing in disguise for her to  be honest it's like his true colors  really showed at the end